foreign
hi there it's the view from 22 and uh
this week like all weeks we're looking
at an issue that isn't getting quite
enough attention
um my name is Igor torini lalic I'm the
Arts editor The Spectator and we're
joined today by Winston Marshall
formerly of Mumford and Sons
so this week we are looking at the um
the route between David Gilmore and
Roger Waters Another Round between these
two um both members of Pink Floyd former
members of Pink Floyd and it involves
Dave Gilmore's wife
who's come out said that Waters is
anti-Semitic to his core a lying
thieving hypocritical tax avoiding lip
syncing misogynistic sick with Envy
megalomaniac
um what where does uh this animus come
from what's the what's the beef between
these two well the story is bigger than
that so not only is it a Twitter spat as
you as you read there that's Polly
Sampson's tweet uh Polly Sampson not
only uh Lyricist for Pink Floyd but also
wife of David Gilmore one of the other
members and still standing members of
Pink Floyd Pink Floyd actually still
exists Roger Waters left the band in
and in fact Pink Floyd put out a song
last year with the lead singer of
Ukrainian band Boombox
in support of uh Ukraine in the war so
Pink Floyd still still there Nick Mason
another original member on on drums this
spot I think
is decades old and and it's now somehow
got to the point where Roger the waters
is speaking to the UN Security Council
it's a it's a whole mess of things all
happening simultaneously for some reason
Putin or the Russian Federation have
asked him to speak
uh on the on the war in the Ukraine as
if as if as this bass player is the
appropriate guy to to to broker piece
um and uh all the while
um there's uh Pink Floyd a disputing uh
or trying to sell their their back
catalog
um uh as well as the fact that Roger
Waters is also just re-recording the Now
50 year old Dark Side of the Moon uh
because it's of some deep bitterness
towards the rest of the band he seems to
think that it was really him who was the
genius and uh and uh that the others are
sort of irrelevant so he's re-recording
it and and intends to put the album out
later this year when he's finished so
it's kind of a weird Mash of kind of a
typical band dispute that's now playing
out on the on the global uh stage
are you enjoying it is this one of the
great musical feuds of all times
enjoying it I'll tell you why I'm not
enjoying it because uh Roger Waters
words and writings are filled with
anti-western anti-jewish rhetoric in his
speech
for the apps to the UN Security Council
he makes more jives at Israel than he
does proffer actual solutions for the
Ukraine Russia War this has all come
about by the way the reason why Putin
has asked him or the Russian Federation
has asked him is because of an interview
he did with the Berliner Berliner
zaitung earlier this month again this
interview littered with anti-western
Jabs and anti-israel Jabs he he Compares
Israel again to Nazi Germany as if what
Israel are doing is any way comparable
to the slaughter of six million Jews he
says that he would not he would
absolutely play in Russia if he could
but he would not if there was anyone to
boycott for political reasons apparently
it's America now also keep in mind that
he's part of BDS boycott divestment
sanctions and so boycott Israel so uh
this would be uh fun if it wasn't so so
laced with
um what I consider pretty hateful stuff
well hang on you're a big supporter of
um free speech not getting canceled
um
but you seem to be varying over into the
side of um canceling him
well no I wouldn't go that far I I um I
do believe in free speech I also believe
in uh the right to criticize and I also
believe in the right of Association I
didn't say anything about uh canceling
him in fact Poland have I think canceled
some of his shows because of uh what um
uh he has said on Ukraine in fact it
seems to me that it's Roger Waters who's
canceling Israel
um if anyone's doing the canceling and I
I I'll stand by my right to criticize
him for doing that
you famously split with the band that
you were a member of Mumford and Sons um
what does it feel like when
that happens when someone some you know
a group of people you've been working
with so intensely they turn on you or
they split away from you or you you turn
away from them how did that feel
well I think it's certainly uh the case
that if you know to have a public
opinion to express your point of view uh
in in the public domain is perilous now
the specific thing that I I expressed
was a condemnation of far left extremism
of the BLM Riot and and this was done by
recommending a book that documented that
behavior in in 2020 in America uh now
there were
repercussions for that
radio sessions said that they would stop
playing the music of the band uh one
Festival in the UK dropped me as a DJ
without letting me know and so you if
you have the wrong opinions
certainly there there are there is uh
punishment for that in if the music
industry is a very small industry it's
one with a
strong group thing a homogeneous thought
and outliers are often punished and so
uh I would say in my case it wasn't fair
on the band for them to suffer the
consequences of what I think are quite
reasonable opinions but in the music
industry apparently not and so I thought
it was best for me to step away from the
band to save them uh that um difficulty
um now if if Pink Floyd was still
together uh if any of them
who would have stepped away who would
have stayed by each other well it's hard
to hard to play out it seems like that
their their beef is is uh is pretty deep
and um if that it's a sort of it's come
to the fact that they're sort of
slinging insults at each other on
Twitter it sort of implies it's not
necessarily just about their politics
that there's actually a deep personal
Rift there that goes back many decades
Waters has said that actually you know
he's the driving force behind the band
he's he's the creative genius
um and they were they they sank into you
know into
into crap after after he left them
um is is that is that right do you think
certainly their most successful albums
came while he was still in in the band
whether whoever wrote the most amount of
songs and he claims it although the song
credits sort of seemed to suggest uh
more collaborative or even different
story
um there's a tension when you're all in
the band together and you feed off each
other and just the simple face of of
your band mate might lead you in a in a
different different way or the smallest
suggestions the mood of the room affect
the songwriting massively so there's no
doubt that Pink Floyd at their best was
when the four of them worked well
actually Pink Floyd to be honest there
was also the the Sid Barrett period as
well so bands change through time and
and the connection between the the
individuals in the group massively
affects the outcome of of the of the
albums and the records and songs and the
the tension between them do you think
that might maybe sort of spurred on that
period of
creativity that you think was the best
it's certainly my favorite uh Pink Floyd
albums were when those guys were
together now I I'm not enough of a pink
floydian expert to uh to to really know
uh their interactions in in in in in the
in the band but I think Dark Side of the
Moon if record sales is a testament for
anything and it's a 50 year old album
this year I think it sold 50 million
records which is still one of the
highest selling records of all time and
if that's anything to go by that does
suggest that there that there was
something there was a magic when those
guys were together
I mean artists this he wouldn't be the
first artist to have had an extreme
crazy thought I mean it's part and part
of being an artist to live on the edges
of what's acceptable in in Social terms
political terms and creative terms
that's that's how you that's why you get
people of vision and genius within art
because they explore these quite sort of
um uh dark nether worlds that no one
else us normies wouldn't dare explore
um so isn't it part and parcel of being
an artist I mean wacky ideas stupidities
have always come from artists brains and
mouths I think you've got a point there
and we saw this with Kanye West as well
where he's been right on the edge I mean
I do consider Kanye a musical genius and
I think many people will consider Roger
Waters a musical genus he's able to go
out there into the chaos and and make
sense of of it and and and his mind is
uh that their minds are able to to and
we need their minds to to be let loose
and and explore that that territory so I
think you're absolutely correct it is
part and parcel of of the creative uh
mind and and we should expect that but
but when they cross the line I think
it's absolutely acceptable to criticize
them for doing so
do you think at the moment though um
really the the wind is blowing against
those who are who have views that are
supportive of Russia I mean the the the
people have been canceled who are really
being canceled at the moment are artists
who are Russian I mean just being
Russian will get you canceled
in in film competitions in music
competitions in on the Opera stage I I'm
now not allowed not able to hear one of
the greatest living conductors Valerie
gergive or several singers opera singers
because just because they're Russian
mm-hmm this is the the real threat to to
our free freedom of speech at the moment
is is Russians getting canceled for
being of an ethnicity that people don't
like at the moment
I think you're absolutely right and
we've even seen the case that there are
Russian artists who are explicitly
Auntie Putin who are still having their
work removed I think you'll remember uh
and that this was perhaps the the nadir
of the lunacy last year when in at Milan
University dostoesky was removed from
the syllabus because it was deemed
Russian that you're absolutely right
it's gone way too far I would even yeah
I I I I I think that that there's a
there's a there's a sense of of
overreach and um and I'm I'm again I
think that there is a reasonable
conversation to have and that Roger
Waters could have
um but he goes uh way too far I believe
artists in general
need to have this space need to have
this leg room to think
kind of crazy things
um at the moment
especially within pop music
there is a liberal conformity
um threatening that ability
do you see that I mean on on all sides I
mean the way that you know what you
thought was treated in the way that
Roger Waters Waters thinks is treated do
we not need more space and how do we
find that space in a in a world which is
so constrained not just by sort of
people who want to stop the way people
think but also by money which which
really which really doesn't want people
to stray outside a tiny narrow confines
of what the advertisers will allow
if if the if what the conversation is
opened up by by someone like Waters or
someone like Kanye West then perhaps
there's a there's a good thing but so I
wouldn't necessarily say oh well in fact
I would absolutely defend their their
right to free speech but we must meet
this folly or these bad ideas with good
ideas and they must be criticized
because they are so woeful if you look
through all of Roger Waters interviews
and his public statements he is so
anti-western he cannot it's almost like
even any even in his speech to the U.N
security Council he seems it seems to be
more a dig at How the West is run rather
than how the um Russia when it was the
whole speech was about the Russia
Ukraine war I think it's uh of course we
should accept these people uh to have we
must defend their their free speech
whether we invite them to speak at the
UN Security Council there's a whole
other thing completely
is it is it a a business move to be
canceled I mean getting canceled is
quite a quite useful for you for ticket
sales uh depending on which field you're
you're in I mean hasn't been that useful
for me
um you're right though actually when I
uh
quit the band there was a bump in
streaming on on the band all published
here is good publicity they say although
on a personal level it's not been good
at all for me uh either financially or
in the pursuit of my passion for music
um it sort of depends on on the
circumstance I guess it'd be interesting
to know how exactly this is profitable
for Roger Waters is is him rallying
against
Russia is this going to make his deal
with this bundle deal to sell his back
catalog full through there is some
suggestion that it might it's probably
more complicated than that is it is he
doing that to SM to spite his
ex-bandmates because he's considerably
wealthier than they are
um as well so there's so there's so much
at play to know whether it's really
profitable it may be profitable to some
perhaps the the record labels I mean if
you look at what's happening with Sam
Smith he's he's
been across the news over the last
couple of weeks because of his various
outfits and performances including a
performance at the Grammy Awards where
he's dressed like a a like a demon and a
highly sexualized
um stage outfit and and highly
provocative and the attention he's
getting and then as well turning up to
the Brits in what looks like a a sort of
wetsuit he's farted into he he's getting
a lot of attention and that will
actually and be good for business
because as Oscar Wilde said the only
thing worse than uh not being uh sorry
them being talked about is not being
talked about so yeah for some artists
it's a good thing and just a final
question I mean what does it feel like
going on tour once you've been kind of
canceled or had you know so much a
problem sort of voice it upon you I mean
you've been in that situation what I
mean does it you know how does it feel
well for me I went from
uh being a part of Arena band headlining
um headlining festivals and now uh my
latest tour has been considerably small
smaller uh venues playing solo shows and
to be honest I'm I'm really enjoying it
it's complete it's like it wasn't for me
when I started 15 years ago in the old
days but uh it's it's certainly
um it's
a stripped back set you could say
thank you for for joining us
[Music]